a very strange anomaly sits in a
humanoid containment cell in the minimum
security wing of site-17 he walks talks
and looks like a man but everything else
is convoluted in a question mark this is
scp-343 who like his namesake god is
likely to cause arguments whenever he's
brought up is he the creator of all that
exists the basis for the abrahamic
faiths or is he a pretender a reality
warper with immense power and
predilection towards delusion a courtesy
and of the house of maladrog matthew
methuselah yahweh who knows really it
depends on who you ask and which stories
you choose to believe and few people
enjoy a good story more than scp-343
himself if one day you take the time to
visit him in his room and ask him to
reveal a page in the long book of his
personal history he might be kind enough
to tell you a story a story like this of
an encounter with something monstrous
that few others could hope to survive
meeting face to face rewind a few
thousand years nobody knows how many
exactly god as he chooses to dub himself
walked across the cracked ground on worn
sandals he'd been some time since he'd
seen an animal around here and even
longer since he'd seen a human being not
that this bothered him he'd never been
bothered by his own company on a long
walk like this of course he could have
sped up time or teleported but where was
the fun in that he was a tourist in the
world of sensation of experience of
flesh bone dirt blood and sand after all
where's the fun in creating a whole
universe if you can't drop in now and
then to visit and do as the romans do
not that the romans would be around for
another few thousand years even atlas
must occasionally shift the weight of
the globe from his shoulders for a jaunt
around the cosmic neighborhood and
whatever passes for fresh air in the
vacuum god whistled the tune to himself
it was a craggy mountainous region he'd
found himself in the distant peaks had
frosted caps a breath taking place where
many truly had their breaths taken away
how humans will so happily risk their
lives to do something extraordinary it
never ceased to amaze him his stomach
rumbled oh how he enjoyed that sensation
one of the funny little quirks of this
human form that he weaved for himself it
was no reason to be concerned if memory
served from his last trip through the
area a few decades before there was a
friendly village not far from here they
had always accepted him as a genial
stranger having no knowledge of his true
power god had always believed that a
person's goodness is defined by how they
treat those from whom they had nothing
to gain so it caused him great concern
as he approached the village and saw
great plumes of smoke rising into the
sky he was so shocked by this that he
could decide to break his rule about
walking as a man in case there was still
some way he could help with a snap of
his fingers he disappeared and
reappeared in the center of the
village's town square total devastation
huts and houses had been torn asunder
broken weapons lay on the ground some
places were on fire others smeared with
streaks of blood like some terrible
battle had occurred here but something
was wrong no bodies not one from
defender or assailant how could a
thriving village be so thoroughly
destroyed and not leave a single corpse
it was an act so bizarre and depraved
that it left even god puzzling that was
another downside of his human form here
on earth he didn't have access to true
omniscience how could a mere human mind
bound by the constraints of linear time
ever truly comprehend the total of
existence even attempting to do that
here would melt the brain of his human
body and its skull
and leave it dribbling out of his nose
and ears instead he chose to walk around
the ruins of the village and investigate
firsthand arrows and broken spears and
swords littered the ground some
buildings were demolished but there were
no tracks or stray projectiles that
could suggest the presence of siege
weapons now these buildings look like
they were ripped apart some even still
had claw marks what terrible beast could
have set upon this town and done this
then he heard a voice quiet and pleading
beneath some nearby rubble a survivor he
rushed over to the pile and evaporated
it with a thought underneath a feeble
old man covered in stone dust was
quivering god helped him up and guided
him into one of the few remaining huts
still standing in the village they both
took seats god held up two hands
cradling empty space two cups suddenly
occupied that space both filled with
warm healing tea he passed the old man
one of the cups while sipping from his
own he asked the old man if he'd seen
what had happened the old man told him
no he hadn't seen anything in decades
he'd been rendered blind in his youth
little did either of them know that very
blindness was the only reason he was the
sole survivor of the massacre the blind
man told god that one of the village's
scouts had gone up into the mountain
with a small hunting party the group was
gone for days until one of the members
the youngest among them returned weeping
frostbitten and covered in blood he said
that his friends had been killed by a
beast in the mountains something that
almost looked like a man but terribly
wrong and its face
its awful awful face he would never
forget it he was just lucky to escape
with his life when the others were torn
apart but when the young man returned
he'd brought the shadow of death with
him it was a curse that doomed the
entire village men woman and children to
a terrible fate and that fate was upon
them a mere hour after the survivor had
returned of course there were gaps in
the blind man's understanding given he
was lacking one of his major senses but
the sounds he could describe with
perfect clarity it was faint and distant
at first that awful whale and the
galloping hands and feet thundering
against the ground faster than any horse
could move getting closer and closer
another villager saw it approaching and
screamed then it was upon them the
villagers screamed but it screamed
louder always wailing and shrieking and
sobbing like a monster crawling straight
up from hell people tried to fight it by
the sounds of it the blind man with
teary blank eyes recalled the sounds of
arrows knocking and swords clashing
against
something but even their greatest
warriors had screamed and died those who
saw it and tried to flee and hide were
slaughtered all the same soon enough
there were only two sounds left in the
village the monster and the blind man
both weeping he didn't understand why it
never took him it wasn't fair it took
everything else to leave him here alive
when everyone and everything he'd ever
known was destroyed was a greater
punishment than even death after killing
all of these innocents the monster had
simply wandered off to the mountains
again the sound of its quiet sobs
getting smaller and smaller until it was
gone altogether god comforted the blind
man as he wept for the loss of all his
loved ones he told the blind man that he
would venture up to the mountains
himself and confront the creature on its
own territory and at the very least find
out why it had done this terrible thing
but first he must relocate the blind man
to a safer place he placed a hand on the
blind man's shoulder and he vanished he
would appear in another friendly village
miles away god sent a silent message
into the minds of every villager take
good care of this man
he has undergone horrors you can't even
imagine
your kindness will be rewarded later for
that
you have my promise
god sighed and turned his tired eyes to
the distant mountains a monster lurked
up there perhaps one of his own
creations or maybe a corruption of one
of his creations either way whatever
existed without his knowledge existed
without his consent and he intended to
know of the beast in the mountains
though given what he'd seen already he
didn't expect to receive a warm welcome
from this murderous demon miles away up
in the mountains the creature licked the
blood from its cracked lips it looked
like it might have once been a human
being or something that aspired to
humanity or mocked it with its very
existence it was a huge gangling beast
skin alablaster eyes empty and soulless
dribbling rivulets of burning tears down
a hideous gaunt face he crawled into the
frozen mouth of a cave with great icicle
fangs wheezing and weeping all it ever
wanted was to be alone why did they have
to keep interfering didn't they know
what happened all the terrible things
they made it do the creature curled its
long gangly body into the fetal position
scratching great ruts into the sides of
its bald cranium with long sharp fingers
terrible things terrible terrible things
and then there was a brilliant flash
just a few feet away the monster was
surprised he'd turned to see a figure
silhouetted in the mouth of the cave he
wore sandals and thin robes his eyes
glowed with a kind of power that the
monster didn't recognize this stranger
stared at the monster without an ounce
of fear in his heart he stared right
into its eyes unwavering no no no no no
no he could feel it again the rage
bubbling up deep down a cauldron of
seething anger it hated the feeling like
being lowered into a vat of molten metal
unspeakable fire and pain coursing
through every vessel he began to weep
and scream while the stranger in the
cave mouth just watched not moving a
muscle do you know who i am
the stranger asked with a deep voice
that betrayed almost infinite power
knowledge and wisdom but it wouldn't
change the outcome here the monster
bounded at him at speeds that wouldn't
be seen again until jet planes and
bullet trains are invented millennia
into the future its jaws were hanging
impossibly wide fangs born its arms
extended and deadly claws ready to
strike but before those terrible hands
could close around the stranger he
vanished the monster stumbled and rolled
across the snow confused what trickery
was being used here i'll take that as a
no
said the voice from behind him you want
to show your father some respect
more respect than you gave to those poor
people down in the village at least
seething the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness
of the cave staring at him but the beast
didn't have the capacity for awe or holy
terror only violence boundless limitless
unstoppable violence it darted towards
the stranger again trying to strike him
somehow it was like fighting an empty
robe not a single one of its deadly
strikes seemed to hit the stranger the
stranger leaped backwards putting some
space between himself and the monster
but still not breaking a sweat he
breathed in deeply then exhaled the
breath came out like a mighty typhoon
shocking even the monster with its
sudden force it was blown backwards a
leaf in the wind until its long claws
dug into the ground and anchored it in
place the stranger gave a wry smile at
this impressed my mind you're certainly
a tenacious one aren't you
he said perhaps we can talk for a little
while instead of fighting
i want to know why you killed all those
people
no answer the beast roared its mighty
limbs pounding into the ground as it
closed the gap between itself and the
stranger in fractions of a second it
would kill him rent him destroy him just
like all the others he'd left it no
choice suddenly the ground below it
seemed to give way the creature was
confused he looked down to see that the
ancient stone below had somehow taken on
the properties of a liquid and it was
sinking the beast panicked and it began
to thrash it was a strong swimmer but it
didn't expect to need to swim here the
shock was too much and soon the ground
submerged it entirely muffling its
terrible roars and shrieks and just like
that the ground was solid again trapping
the beast inside the stranger stepped
forward and looked at the ground a much
needed timeout
he said you do yourself no good
struggling like this
despite its terrible capacity for evil
god couldn't help but admire the beast
at least on the level of construction it
was so paired down so unburdened a
killer to the core but seemingly
unkillable had he made this creature
billions of species and the species
those in turn had created through
billions of years of breeding and
evolution and somewhere along the line
this thing happened it was easy even for
the universe's creator to lose track of
some of the tinier variables and in the
grand scheme of things even this monster
was still a tiny variable but right here
right now it was still one hell of a
problem the ground rumbled below god
cracks formed the mountain peak shook
god raised an eyebrow genuinely
impressed as the monster ripped free of
its stone prison and re-entered the fray
it roared and screamed still its blank
eyes fixed on him his skeletal body
throbbed and heaved with power unlike
any other creature in nature it was
almost like the longer their conflict
went on the more energized the beast
became god's side all those poor
villagers they never stood a chance
against this monster it lunged for him
even faster and stronger than before he
teleported out of the way in the nick of
time and the beast's claws cleaved
through a nearby cave wall effortless
god materialized nearby but he didn't
have time to speak the beast lunged
again and again and again
every time he reappeared the beast went
for him with impossible speed deciding
to widen the playing field god
teleported to the top of the mountain
the creature somehow sensing his
presence vaulted upwards and tunneled
through the roof of the cave bursting
out of the ground in front of god who
was floating just slightly off the
ground it would be wise of you to stop
god carefully and toned all this time
you know i've been going easy on you
you don't want to find out what the
wrath of god looks like
storm clouds were gathering above mighty
thunder roared across the sky the beast
was undeterred it roared and galloped
towards god and god in turn called down
a response a volley of lightning the
likes of which the world has never seen
before or since struck down on the
charging monster the sudden white flash
could sting the eyes from miles away the
monster shrieked from the blast feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and
atomizing the sheer heat of the
electricity around it it could smell
itself cooking the lightning blast only
lasted for a few seconds but for the
beast it felt like eternity when the
onslaught stopped the air was still
heavy with electrical potential god
stared down at the black scorch mark on
the side of the mountain where the
creature had been standing all the snow
within a mile had been evaporated by the
blast it was a raw display of the power
of nature that would make even zeus
tremble in his sandals and yet
there was still movement some things
started to get up from the burnt patch
where nothing should be left alive
a blackened skeleton rising shakily from
the ash but still very much alive as it
started to rise new flesh began growing
over its bones little by little even god
was astonished by the sight of it he'd
never seen a creature cling so ardently
to life in spite of having truly
unsurmountable power amassed against it
it was up against god and still it
fought the monster tottered on its
freakishly long limbs still disoriented
unusually staggered for a creature
driven by such single-minded violent
purpose when enough of its face grew
back to do so it began to weep and sob
again tears streaking down its terrible
face looking at this creature after all
of this god couldn't help but feel a new
emotion pity he lowered himself to the
ground and approached the creature like
none had ever done before he gathered it
up into his arms and he held it feeling
its heaving wretched sobs against him
the beast was in so much pain he could
feel it radiating from within
spook
god said in a soft fatherly voice and
for the first and only time the monster
spokes
[Applause]
that was all it managed to choke out
before devolving back into
unintelligible babble but it was enough
enough for god to understand its pain he
did not know if it would be right to
change the monster's nature is it ever
right to truly change anyone's nature
but it was within his almost limitless
power to grant it one reprieve from pain
he settled the beast in the snow below
him it was quiet and still and god said
unto the beast rest now child
rest for thousands of years if you must
i hope only that when you eventually
awaken
you feel differently
and so another story from the catalog of
scp-343
of course it leaves us with certain
questions chief among them being is it
true did 343 and 096 have this chance
encounter long ago or is this just
another tall tale from an anomaly who
fancies himself a deity we have our
truth and you have yours let us know
what you believe down below in the
comments now go check out scp-096 shy
guy escape incident 096-1-8
containment breach and your questions
for god answered for more fascinating
tales of the anomalies featured in this
video